la semana de la crítica de este festival
de cannes cuenta con dos películas de
hispanoamérica seleccionadas ayer se
estrenó amparo del colombiano simón mesa
él estuvo en el 2014 ganó la competencia
de cortometrajes volvió en el 2016 con
otro cortometraje y este es su primer
largo amparo cuenta la historia de una
madre soltera que tiene dos hijos el
mayor de ellos desaparece ya descubre
que ha sido reclutado por el ejército
para ir a combatir a una zona
conflictiva de colombia la crítica
celebró la película porque el director
no exagera el drama que vive en sus
personajes al contrario estos parecen en
ciertas formas indiferentes a las
tragedias que les toca vivir y si no en
la competencia oficial del festival
regresa hoy un conocido el iraní asghar
farhadi recordemos que estuvo en el 2018
con una película muy internacional
protagonizada por penélope cruz y javier
bardem esta vez regresa con un filme más
bien iraní se llama el héroe cuenta la
historia de un hombre que está preso por
haber hecho una estafa pero que tiene
dos días de libertad en los que
intentará convencer a su acreedor para
llegar a un pacto y poder recuperar su
libertad